hi wir sind wieder für euch ZDF heute
live ganz herzlich willkommen bei uns im
Stream schön dass ihr bei uns seid wir
berichten für euch immer wieder in den
vergangenen Wochen und auch Monaten über
die Situation rund um den russischen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine und das
machen wir auch heute Abend wieder weil
der Trend weiter anhält dass die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte Gebiete
zurückerobern und militärische Erfolge
feiern
im Süden ist es aktuell so dass dort die
ukrainischen Truppen aus mehreren
Richtungen auf die regionale Hauptstadt
[Musik]
könnte kurz vor der Befreiung stehen das
ist deswegen wichtig weil dort die
Wasserversorgung zur Krim hinläuft also
von enormer strategischer Bedeutung und
damit dann auch ein wichtiger Erfolg für
die Ukraine den gibt's womöglich auch im
Osten des Landes und auf der anderen
Seite sind diese Erfolge also die
Ukraine hat die Erfolg auf ihrer Seite
für die russischen Streitkräfte sind es
natürlich große und herberückschläge und
deswegen ist unser Thema auch heute
bricht die russische Front
zusammenbricht Putins Front damit
zusammen hier haben wir es für euch
eingeblendet
zu dieser Frage liefert uns heute der
ehemalige Nato-General Egon Rams
ausführliche Hintergründe Einschätzungen
und natürlich auch Analysen und dann
blicken wir auch noch nach Kiew in die
Ukraine Alisa jung ist dafür uns vor Ort
und versorgt uns auch mit einem
Stimmungsbild wie es in der Bevölkerung
dort aussieht wir alle wir freuen uns
natürlich wenn ihr Teil der Sendung seid
und um Fragen stellt Einschätzungen
liefert Hintergründe könnt ihr wie immer
tun gerne in die Kommentare oder auch
per Mailadresse kommt das ist ZDF
heute-live@zdf.de
den ersten Überblick jetzt aber über die
aktuelle Situation von beiden Seiten den
hat Lena sünderburg für uns und sie
beginnt erneut mit dem Bruch Russlands
mit dem Völkerrecht
sieben Monate nach Kriegsbeginn und
zusammen mit der Krim kontrolliert
Russland nun etwa ein Sechstel des
ukrainischen Staatsgebiets Präsident
Putin vollendet formal die
völkerrechtswidrige Annexion der Gebiete
lohansk Donetzk saporija und herson
diese Worte aus dem Kreml klingen
deshalb zynisch
wir machen keinen Unterschied zwischen
Russen und Ukrainern das haben wir nie
getan und werden es auch nicht tun aber
wenn wir unseren eigenen Weg gehen und
ich glaube dass dieser Weg schöpferisch
ist werden wir ohne jeden Zweifel alles
abschneiden was uns daran hindert
voranzukommen
ganz anders und ungewöhnlich offen
äußert sich der Vorsitzende des
russischen Verteidigungsausschusses im
messenger-dienst telegram die Armee
müsse mit dem Lügen über den
Militäreinsatz aufhören
wie Russland in den zwangsweise
eingegliederten Gebieten die Grenzen
ziehen will ist unklar denn Moskau
beherrscht aktuell nur Teile dieser
Regionen hier orange
die ukrainische Armee hat laut Präsident
selenski mittlerweile dutzende
Ortschaften zurückerobert
unsere Kämpfer hören nicht auf und es
ist nur eine Frage der Zeit bis wir die
Besatzer aus unseren ganzen Land
vertrieben haben alle russischen
Beschlüsse alle Verträge mit denen sie
versuchen sich unseres Landes zu
bemächtigen all das ist wertlos
ukrainische Einheiten sind auch in
Luciani eingerückt ein strategisch
wichtiges Dorf am Fluss von dort ist ein
Vorstoß auf die von Russland besetzte
Hafenstadt herson am Schwarzen Meer
möglich und wahrscheinlich
Russlands Antwort auf die ukrainischen
Erfolge Drohnenangriffe nahe Kiew
ein Aspekt auf den wir später in der
Sendung noch weiter zu sprechen kommen
wir wollen jetzt aber Egon Rams der
ehemalige Nato-General zu uns dazu holen
vorab da haben wir Ihnen Herr Rams
vielen Dank dass Sie heute bei uns sind
und danke gut dass wir ihre Expertise
heute haben
schönen guten Morgen hoch
Herr Rams Frage direkt an sie bricht die
russische Front bricht die Front Putins
da gerade in ihre Einzelteile
das sehe ich so noch nicht die Russen
haben noch genügend Kräfte in der
Ukraine sowohl im Süden als auch im
Osten und es ist letztendlich eine Frage
der geschickten Befehlsgebung und der
geschickten Führung um hier wieder einen
Zusammenhalt aus russischer Sicht
herzustellen dass es sicherlich
schwierig aufgrund der entschlossen
geführten Angriffe der ukrainischen
Truppen und auch der guten qualitativ
guten Führung der Ukrainer und der
enormen Moral die die ukrainische
Streitkräfte zeigen aber von einem
Zusammenbruch zu reden ist in meinen
Augen zu früh das bedarf glaube ich noch
vieler weiterer Kampfhandlungen wird
noch viele Menschen leben Kosten
ein Kommentar der dazu bei Youtube
reinkommt von Felder fahre auch er geht
in dieselbe Richtung und sagt also ob
die Front jetzt komplett zusammenbricht
das wagt auch der User zu bezweifeln
allerdings Rennen die Russen das ist das
Zitat an vielen Abschnitten wie die
Hasen und das hat ja auch die russische
Seite zugegeben dass es an der
Frontlinie sozusagen Soldatinnen und
Soldaten gibt die sich zurückziehen
vielleicht geben Sie uns einen über was
ist da aktuell die Situation
also ich schätze das so ein dass die
ukrainischen Kräfte die ukrainischen
Soldaten sehr erfolgreich angreifen ich
schätze das so ein dass den Russen
möglicherweise Voraussetzungen fehlen um
mir das Gefecht weiterzuführen das
beginnt mit der Versorgung der
russischen Soldaten setzt sich fort mit
der entsprechenden Logistik hinsichtlich
Munition Betriebsstoffe und dergleichen
mehr wenn meine Kampffahrzeuge nicht
mehr fahren wenn ich nicht mehr schießen
kann dann bleibt mir im Prinzip nichts
anderes übrig als mich zu ergeben oder
praktisch die Flucht anzutreten und das
ist das was wir offensichtlich hier in
einigen Abschnitten sehen und was auch
ein bisschen damit korrespondiert was im
Augenblick berichtet wird wo sich auch
hohe russische offizielle Jahr darüber
beschweren das offensichtlich die
Führung des Generalstabes auf der einen
Seite aber auch die Logistik für die
russischen Truppen nicht funktioniert
jetzt haben wir diesen Aspekt
thematisiert gibt es darüber hinaus noch
weitere Aspekte die sie gerade aus ihrer
Expertise und Analyse sehen die die
ukrainische Seite gerade so stark machen
und die russische Seite offenbar so
schwach
also ist sieht so aus dass auf der einen
Seite die seitens des Westens
gelieferten Waffen die Ukraine dazu
befähigen auch hinter die Kampflinien
der russischen Seite zu wirken damit die
Versorgung zur unterbrechen Depots zu
zerstören logistische Schwerpunkte zu
zerstören aber auch gefechtstände und
Kommando Posten zu zerstören so dass
damit auch die Führung für die in
russischen Einheiten ausgesprochen
schwierig wird dabei muss man auch noch
anmerken dass der Generalstab diese
Operationen ja von Moskau ausführt und
die russischen Kommandeure zumindest in
einem weiten Bereich keine Möglichkeit
haben eigenständig zu agieren und auf
die ich sag mal sehr überraschenden
Bedrohungen die dort durch die
ukrainischen Angriffe entstehen zu
reagieren und das macht die Sachen auch
die Sache auch für die russischen
Kommandeure und die russischen Soldaten
nicht einfacher man muss allerdings auch
festhalten dabei dass die russischen
Soldaten für eine ich nenne das mal
Auftragstaktik in unserem Sinne und
bewegliche gefechtsführung nicht
ausgebildet sind von daher dürfte ich
hier einen
Systemwechsel in der Führung während
eines laufenden Krieges nahezu unmöglich
sein was verändert das auch in Sachen
Kampfmoral auf beiden Seiten diese
aktuelle Situation
ja je mehr Erfolge die Ukraine haben die
ja praktisch vom ersten Kriegstag an
eine wahnsinnig hohe Kampfmoral und
Entschlossenheit ihr Land zu verteidigen
gezeigt haben je mehr Erfolge die haben
desto schwieriger wird die Situation für
die Russen und wenn russische Soldaten
sehen wie in einem nachbarabschnitt ihre
Kameraden die Soldaten aus Russland die
Flucht antreten dann wissen Sie genau
dass sie damit auch selber offene
Flanken bekommen und damit eine
schwierige Situation kommen und
schließen sich dann den Flüchtling
möglicherweise an das heißt je größer
die Erfolge der ukrainischen Seite
werden desto schwieriger wird es die
russischen Truppen zu führen und
vielleicht eine neue Verteidigungslinie
an anderer Stelle aufzubauen und ein
Aspekt den sie gerade schon angerissen
haben vielleicht vertiefen wir den an
der Stelle noch mal ganz kurz neben
Kriegsführung haben sie angesprochen
neben Kampfmoral die sich verändert dem
kriegspsychologie oder auch einem Bild
in welcher Situation man reingeht ist ja
auch ein weiterer entscheidender Punkt
das Thema Waffen auf welchem Stand sind
da gerade beide Seiten
also ich glaube dass die Unterschiede in
der Bewaffnung der ukrainischen Truppen
und der russischen Truppen zumindest was
das Gefecht der Infanterie der
Panzersoldaten der Atelier angeht nicht
so unterschiedlich sind bei der
Artillerie muss ich eine Anmerkung
machen hier spielt eine Rolle das wie
der Westen moderne Waffensystem ich
denke an die Panzerhaubitze 2000 an dem
mehrfach Raketenwerfer ich denke an
Heimat seitens der Amerikaner
ataviesysteme geliefert haben die eine
weitaus tiefer reichende Wirkung in den
russischen Bereich hinein haben also die
russischen Geschütze können und es zeigt
auch der Versuch andere Drohnen oder
andere Mittel einzusetzen das ist
offensichtlich hier bei den Russen
erheblich mangelt
befassen also zusammen es gibt
Rückeroberungen es gibt eine Veränderung
in der Kampfmoral der Truppen der
russischen Truppen die Tendenz zeigt da
ganz klar nach unten eine
Demoralisierung es gibt offenbar
Schwierigkeiten bei der Versorgung alles
Punkte die wir an der Stelle jetzt
rausgearbeitet haben blicken wir dann
auf die Reaktion Russlands vielleicht
auch auf die Reaktion Putins wir sehen
kein Eingeständnis dass Selbstbild
bleibt weiter es gibt kein zurück und es
gibt sogar den Versuch der weiteren
Eskalation das haben wir auch
mitbekommen er hat heute auch offiziell
das Gesetz zur Annektion der
ukrainischen Gebiete nur Hans in den
Region Johannes Kresse und saporicia und
Don jetzt unterschrieben ein Brauch
haben wir auch ausgearbeitet mit dem
Völkerrecht heranz was aber bei diesem
Punkt und das kommt auch als Frage
sozusagen in den Kommentaren immer
mitschwingt ist ja die Frage was will er
damit bewirken womöglich ein groß
Szenario ein säbelrassen aufbauen ein
nuklearen Erstschlag ja dann zu machen
also zunächst sehe ich das noch einmal
so dass er durch seine Drohungen die er
ausspricht auch durch sein Verhalten
welches heute ja auch in dem Bericht
vorhin ihrer Kollegin gezeigt worden ist
deutlich machen will dass er weiterhin
Erfolgschancen sieht wobei ja auch schon
die Frage was hat er denn eigentlich
annektiert eine interessante Frage ist
wir haben ja Bereiche der genannten
Regionen die überhaupt nicht in der Hand
der russischen Seite sind wie kann er
Geländer annektieren welches sich nicht
im russischen Besitz befindet und dieses
als russisches Land bezeichnen auf dem
sich ukrainische Truppen und ukrainische
Bürger bewegen bzw aufhalten das heißt
es sind für mich aber im Augenblick
erkennbar ich will vielleicht eine Art
Durchhalteparolen mit denen er in der
Öffentlichkeit zeigen will dass er die
Führung dieser Operation und der ist ja
der oberste Befehlshaber nach wie vor in
der Hand hat wobei ich denke das steht
auf ziemlich wackligen Füßen zurzeit und
wenn die Russen in diesem Bereich keine
Erfolge in absehbarer Zeit erringen dann
wird sich das auch im innenpolitischen
Bereich in Russland durchaus negativ
auswirken
Aspekt Gefahr des nuklearen Erstschlags
wie groß schätzen sie da die Gefahr ein
also ich halte das im Augenblick auch
immer noch für ich sage das mal ein
säbelrassen beziehungsweise eine Drohung
die ist auch gegen den Westen gerichtet
er weiß dass er mit dieser Drohung im
Westen Angst schafft und möglicherweise
die geschlossene Front der Staaten der
NATO und der Europäischen Union
aufbrechen kann aber ich glaube dass er
dabei auch andere Auswirkungen im
politischen aber auch im auspolitischen
Bereich nicht hinreichend kalkuliert es
gibt einige Länder die an einem solchen
nuklearen taktischen nuklearen Einsatz
kein Interesse haben das ist
beispielsweise auch Weißrussland denn
Weißrussland wäre mit Blick auf
nuklearen Fallout beispielsweise bei
einsätzenden Kiew oder etwas weiter
nördlich davon ebenfalls betroffen das
heißt er trifft damit eigene Freundes
der eigene Punkt dabei ein Teil des
Fallouts wird Richtung Russland ziehen
das heißt er sorgt damit auch für
entsprechende Schäden in seinem eigenen
Land
außenpolitisch spielt eine Rolle das
China als Welthandels macht an einem
solchen nuklearenschlag Interesse haben
kann einfach aus dem Grunde kein
Interesse haben kann weil das dazu führt
dass der Welthandel möglicherweise
zusammenbricht und der große Profiteur
von allem funktionierenden Welthandel
ist China selber dazu kommt auch kommen
auch die sehr deutlichen Worte die der
amerikanische Präsident Joe Biden in der
letzten Woche mehrfach ausgesprochen hat
mit dem Satz don't do it don't do it das
heißt der hat eindringlich davor gewarnt
Nuklearwaffen einzusetzen weil dann eine
weitere Reaktion und sei es
Anführungszeichen nur Anführungszeichen
in Form von neuen Sanktionen oder neuen
Handelsbeschränkungen oder neuen
Einschränkungen für Russland daraus
resultieren werden
wichtig dass Sie uns das hier an der
Stelle bei ZDF heute live genauso klar
und präzise einschätzen herzlichen Dank
für den Moment Herr Rams und eben auch
der Aspekt den sie dabei ansprechen ist
ja wirklich wichtig auch noch mal weiter
rauszuarbeiten jetzt im weiteren Verlauf
bei uns es ist ein Teil der Strategie
Putins immer schon jetzt gewesen im
Verlaufe des Krieges Ängste
Verunsicherung zu schüren sowohl im
Westen hat der Rams gerade gesagt als
natürlich auch in der Ukraine die
entscheidende Frage ist jetzt aber hat
er damit auch Erfolg oder trotzen die
Menschen in der Ukraine diesem
säbelrassen in diesem Angst schüren
darüber können wir jetzt sprechen mit
unserer Reporterin und auch hier
Moderatorin bei ZDF heute live Alicia
jung da haben wir sie ist für uns vor
Ort in Kiew schön guten Abend erstmal
nach Kiefer
guten Abend Christian Alisa du hast den
ganzen Tag über die Stimmung in der
ukrainischen Hauptstadt mitbekommen wie
groß oder wie sehr schätzen denn die
Menschen diese Gefahr ein eines
nuklearenschlags wie ist da die Stimmung
also panisch oder jetzt besonders schwer
besorgt in diesem Moment ist jetzt
niemand das Leben das funktioniert hier
ja auch stand jetzt so normal wie es
geht weiter aber trotz allem die Leute
wollen hier vorbereitet sein und ich war
heute den Tag über eben in Kiew
unterwegs wir haben angefangen sind
erstmal ins Ministerium für Sicherheit
hier vor Ort gegangen haben mit dem
Direktor vor Ort gesprochen wir haben
auch ein paar Bilder die könnt ihr jetzt
gerade dazu sehen und er hat uns eben
erzählt man bereitet sich hier vor man
plant zum Beispiel so etwas wie
sogenannte Evakuierungszentren die
sollen in Schulen sein weil die Schulen
die kennt hier jeder da weiß jeder wo
die sind also im Fall der Fälle und
davon reden wir hier vom Fall der Fälle
dass man also Zeit hat im Falle eines
nuklearen Angriffs hier Menschen zu
versorgen zu evakuieren soll das eben in
Schulen stattfinden und was planen Sie
dafür wir wollen sie das machen sie
wollen natürlich im Fall der Fälle ich
betone das weil es ist eben noch nicht
da dieser Fall zum Glück wollen sie aber
natürlich johtabletten bereitstellen die
haben sie das können wir vielleicht auch
gerade in den Bildern sehen auch auf
Lager das ist wir waren im örtlichen
Distrikt hier von Kiew Zentrum waren
also unten im Keller in einem Bunkern am
Luftschutzbunker aus Sowjet-Zeiten und
da am Regal hat man für rund 100.000
Menschen diese Tabletten vorrätig denn
das ist nämlich auch ein wichtiger Punkt
nur Menschen unter 40 Jahre sollen diese
Tabletten einnehmen und dann sind wir
weiter gezogen heute durch die Stadt
waren nämlich dann auch in einer
Apotheke haben mit einer Apotheke drin
und eben mit Kiefern hier gesprochen und
die hat auch noch mal ganz klar gesagt
das Problem ist dass jetzt gerade sich
natürlich viele Menschen versorgen
wollen also auch Menschen über 40 und
dann kommen ältere Menschen auch zu
ihren Apotheken wollen gerne zur
Vorsicht zur Vorbeugung so eine
Jodtablette kaufen und da rät sie stark
von ab denn das ist eben nur geeignet
für die Menschen unter 40 da erhofft
sich die Apotheke die Apothekerin eben
ein bisschen mehr Informationen die dann
noch gestreut werden soll aber ja die
Nachfrage nach diesen Jodtabletten die
es hier gestiegen jeder zweite der
aktuell zu ihren die Apotheke kommt der
fragt nach diesen Tabletten das heißt
also nochmal zusammengefasst jetzt hier
ist es die Stimmung ist ruhig aber
vorbereitet möchte hier schon jeder sein
zumal auch diese sorgevoll natürlich in
einer nuklearen Gefahr nicht erst seit
gestern sondern seit Anfang des Krieges
hier über den Menschen schwebt und jetzt
natürlich noch ein bisschen mehr als das
in den letzten Monaten vielleicht der
Fall war alles klar also wir sehen die
Vorbereitungen laufen richten aber
vielleicht jetzt dann die Aufmerksamkeit
vielleicht auch auf hoffnungsvolle
Aspekte du hast hast du gerade gesagt
den ganzen Tag über mit vielen
verschiedenen Menschen sprechen können
was haben sie dir denn in Bezug auf die
Meldungen in Bezug auf die
gegenoffensiven auf die militärischen
Erfolge der eigenen Streitkräfte gesagt
da hat man hier natürlich schon Hoffnung
geschöpft weil das jetzt gerade im Süden
also für die ukrainische Seite eben
besser läuft also da sind natürlich
viele hoffnungsvoll hier und wissen aber
trotzdem auch gleichzeitig dass das auch
kein Krieg ist der Morgen beendet sein
wird sondern hier stellt sich jeder auf
eine längere Zeit noch ein die das so
gehen wird und vor allem jetzt auch
gerade das sind ja Sorgen und Ängste die
kennen wir ja sogar auch jenseits der
Ukraine jetzt wo der Winter kommt und
natürlich Energie hier in der Ukraine
besonders auch knapp und teuer werden
könnte wollen sich da auch viele
vorbereiten also ja man ist natürlich
irgendwie Mann und Hoffnung geschöpft
ist optimistisch weil es jetzt gerade im
Süden gut zu laufen scheint für die
ukrainische Armee aber gleichzeitig
möchte man sich nicht nur für nukleare
Angriffe und Sorge vorbereiten sondern
eben auch für den Winter und das ist
schon auch was was viele hier
beschäftigt also ich würde sagen man ist
jetzt in der Bevölkerung hier weiter von
entfernt wahnsinnig optimistisch zu sein
und zu glauben super das ganze das endet
hier morgen und bald ist alles vorbei
nee da ist man hier glaube ich in den
letzten Monaten und Wochen all das was
die Menschen hier erlebt haben wirklich
eines Besseren belehrt worden dass das
hier einfach wirklich noch eine ganz
harte Zeit werden könnte werden wird
vielleicht was hat sich denn dir für ein
Bild der Stadt oder auch dem Leben in
der Stadt präsentiert aktuell in der
aktuellen Situation in diesem
Spannungsfeld zwischen Angst zwischen
aber auch hoffen zwischen Krieg und
irgendwie aber auch weiter leben was was
hast du da erlebt
man muss sich das also jetzt in Kiew in
der Hauptstadt so vorstellen dass das
Leben hier im Prinzip seit dem Sommer ja
zurückgekehrt ist also hier sind
Geschäfte und Restaurants offen solange
eben bis die Sperrstunde dann für den
Abend gilt also ab 11 bis 5 Uhr morgens
meine ich ist es fünf sechs Uhr und
deswegen findet hier natürlich das Leben
so normal wie möglich auf der Straße
statt tagsüber das ist der Fall aber
heute war auf jeden Fall schon auch ein
bisschen im Gespräch ich kann das
nämlich gerne mal zitieren das sind
ukrainische Quellen also heute wurde auf
der Straße schon noch darüber gesprochen
dass sechs Drohnen hier ganz in der Nähe
der Hauptstadt es gab auch Luftalarm in
der Nacht runtergegangen sein sollen
also das sagt die ukrainische Seite das
war der
örtliche Gouverneur der darüber
gesprochen hat dabei soll auch ein
Mensch verletzt worden sein aber vor
allem Infrastruktur getroffen worden
sein sechs weitere Drohnen hätte man
abgefangen so sagt die ukrainische Seite
und das war dann heute schon auch
stattgespräch was die Menschen hier
natürlich dann auch wieder beunruhigt
also es gibt hier immer wieder Dämpfer
das meinte ich ja eben auch in meiner
hin meine Antwort davor also weit weg
von jetzt hier ob du Optimismus und
morgen ist vorbei ihr habt ja auch die
Bilder gesehen am Ende des Beitrags das
danach Zerstörung aus unserer Quelle ist
in dem Fall eben nur die ukrainische
Seite unabhängig konnten wird es nicht
überprüfen aber das macht den Menschen
hier sorge also es ist immer wieder so
ein Spannungsfeld zwischen ja okay
militärisch läuft es im Süden vielleicht
ganz gut aber gleichzeitig ist man hier
weiter von entfernt jetzt besonders
euphorisch zu sein weil das ist einfach
noch nicht die Zeit dafür absolut vielen
Dank Alisa jung für uns vor Ort in Kiew
für dieses Stimmungsbild aus der
ukrainischen Hauptstadt herzlichen dank
dir
und Alisa hat es gerade thematisiert
also offenbar offiziell bestätigt noch
nicht von beiden Seiten Drohnen Angriffe
auf Kiew dann gehen wir dadurch noch mal
in die militärische Analyse mit Egon
Rams Herms sie haben es auch gerade
gehört was sind diesbezüglich ihre
Information
also diese Lage ist schwer einzuschätzen
es handelt sich offensichtlich um die
kampf- oder Kamikaze Drohnen die
Russland durch den Iran geliefert worden
sind
da kommt bei mir als erstes die Frage
auf warum muss Russland auf Drohnen
zurückgreifen die der Iran zur Verfügung
stellt um erneut zivile Ziele zivile
Infrastruktur anzugreifen es macht
keinen Sinn die Anzahl der Drohnen die
offensichtlich Schäden angerichtet haben
oder die die abgefangen worden sind zu
zählen es geht um den Inhalt solcher
Angriffe gegen zivile Infrastruktur was
ganz klar zeigt dass jetzt auch mit den
Mitteln von Drohnen die von einem
anderen Land geliefert worden sind man
weiterhin versucht zivile Infrastruktur
zu zerstören und möglicherweise auch die
Moral in der Zivilbevölkerung zu brechen
wobei ich glaube das wird Putin mit
diesen Drohnen oder mit anderen Mitteln
nicht gelingen einfach aus dem Grunde
nicht weil ähnlich wie die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte ja auch die ukrainische
Bevölkerung eine wahnsinnig hohe Moral
zeigt das kann man daran erkennen wenn u
Brücke Soldaten bestimmte Landstriche
oder Dörfer oder Städte befreit haben
wie die ukrainische Bevölkerung in der
Berichterstattung darauf reagiert und
ich muss sagen ich spreche der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung in dieser Frage
meine uneingeschränkte Bewunderung aus
weil diese Moral und dieses Verhalten
der Zivilbevölkerung natürlich dann auch
wieder die Kampfmoral der ukrainischen
Soldaten stützt absolut was darüber
hinaus auch immer auch von zum Beispiel
Präsident selensky gefordert wird neben
dieser Moral neben dieser Tugend auch
aus der Bevölkerung dass man natürlich
aber auch weitere Unterstützung von
Verbündeten zum Beispiel aus dem Westen
braucht fakt ist ja es wird geholfen
Frage aber an sie wie bewerten Sie es
zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt ist das
ausreichend und wenn Sie mir eine zweite
Frage hinten ran auch noch erlauben
entscheidend wir sind den aktuell die
Signale aus dem Westen dass das auch
nachhaltig geschieht
also was die Bekenntnisse ich fange mal
mit der zweiten Frage an was die
Bekenntnisse angeht die von Politikern
Präsidenten Kanzlern und anderen
hochrangigen Persönlichkeiten aus der
Politik von verschiedensten Ländern
geäußert werden sieht das so aus dass
man ja klar festgestellt hat man will
die Ukraine weiter unterstützen und man
will auch diese Unterstützung nachhaltig
leisten und damit auch lange andauernd
ich glaube alle Politiker Einstieg des
US-Präsidenten die dieses gesagt haben
waren sich dabei darüber im Klaren dass
dieser Krieg nicht morgen übermorgen
vermutlich auch nicht in diesem Jahr
sondern vielleicht irgendwann vielleicht
irgendwann im nächsten Jahr erst beendet
sein wird von daher muss die
Unterstützung fortgesetzt werden die
Amerikaner haben gerade wieder ein neues
militärisches Hilfspaket für die Ukraine
angekündigt da gehören auch wieder
Munitionen und Raketenwerfer mit dazu da
gehören aber auch diesmal gepanzerte
Fahrzeuge mit dazu und das könnte
möglicherweise die Qualität der
Unterstützung seitens der USA in dieser
Richtung verändern weitere sign in diese
Richtung haben wir bisher nicht sondern
wir reden jetzt wieder über den
Ringtausch
beispielsweise über die Schützenpanzer
oder bmp die aufgrund des ringtausches
von Griechenland an die Ukraine
geliefert werden aber dieser Ringtausch
ist aufgrund der sage ich mal nur noch
im beschränkter Anzahl vorhandenen
Waffensysteme sowjetischer
beziehungsweise russischer Bauart
wahrscheinlich irgendwann zu Ende und da
muss man möglicherweise aufgrund der
Lage auch entsprechend neue
Entscheidungen treffen nämlich dass man
dann auch mit westlichen Waffensystemen
immer mit dem berühmten Satz der
schweren Waffen unterstützt wobei ich
erlaube mir dazu eine Anmerkung auch
eine Panzerhaubitze oder ein Flakpanzer
ist eine schwere Waffe von daher die
haben wir geliefert und wo geht's der
Unterschied sein soll zwischen
Kampfpanzer und Schützenpanzern auf der
einen Seite und Flakpanzer und Haubitzen
auf der anderen Seite ist mir nicht ganz
klar ein weiteres wichtiges System was
Deutschland angekündigt hat weiß aber
noch nicht verfügbar ist ist das
Flugabwehrsystem ihres SLM welches dort
hingeliefert werden soll das wäre mit
Blick auf die luftbedrohung von Seiten
der russischen Streitkräfte ein sehr
wertvolles System zur Bekämpfung von
Luftangriffen
eine Frage die ich damit reinehme von
User catico nie der bezieht sich so ein
bisschen jetzt auf die Anzahl wir haben
jetzt darüber gesprochen dass ich die
Signale für die Unterstützung gibt aber
haben Sie Informationen über Bestände
Anzahlen seine Frage ist nämlich gehen
dem besten irgendwann oder jetzt gerade
die lieferbaren Waffen aus
also die Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
haben in ihren Streitkräften und
international Garde relativ große
Vorräte an Waffen weil sie die Waffen
nicht wenn sie nicht mehr gebraucht
werden verschrotten sondern sie lagern
sie ein und von daher stehen dort sogar
von gehe ich aus ich sage das mal zum
Beispiel Schützenpanzer oder Kampfpanzer
in Tausender Zahlen zur Verfügung von
daher dürfte dieses nicht passieren die
Frage bei den amerikanischen
Kampfpanzern ist zum Beispiel eine ganz
andere die es bisher in der
Öffentlichkeit nicht diskutiert worden
die M1 Abrams die die Amerikaner auf
Lager haben sind Fahrzeuge mit
Gasturbine die mit Benzin oder Kerosin
betrieben werden das würde bedeuten dass
man in der Logistik für die Ukraine eine
weitere Versorgungskette aufbauen müsste
und das wäre schwierig von während das
keine bevorzugten Geräte da gäbe
sicherlich andere Kampfpanzer und
Schützenpanzer die der Ukraine dann in
dieser Richtung mehr helfen könnten ohne
zusätzliche Versorgungsketten und
Logistikketten aufbauen zu müssen ich
glaube nicht dass die Westen die Waffen
ausgeht aber wird möglicherweise
irgendwann mit größerer Entschlossenheit
entscheiden müssen ob man auch an eigene
Bestände rangeht das geht möglicherweise
dann auch für die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland wobei Deutschland ja auch
aus dem Beständen der Panzerhaubitzen
bereits auf Material zurückgegriffen hat
welches eigentlich bei uns in
Deutschland und die Truppe gehört
eine weitere Frage vom User Felder fahre
er beschreibt viele Videos die ja
gesehen hat wo die Ukraine schnell mit
sogenannten hammvis vorstoßen seine
Frage ist da ist das eine neue Art der
Kriegsführung indem man die schnellen
Fahrzeuge eher nutzt als schwere Panzer
die Antwort lautet nein also die
Amerikaner planen mit sogenannten
schnellen eingreifdivisionen bereits
seit den 70er und 80er Jahren dafür ist
der haben wir auch ursprünglich mal
beschafft worden er wird im Prinzip so
dafür jetzt eingesetzt
2022 worüber man in den 80er und 90er
Jahren darüber nachgedacht hat wie man
eine künftige Kriegführung gestalten
könnte aber da haben wir jetzt natürlich
den Vorteil dass er tatsächlich sehr
schnell und sehr beweglich ist und damit
zumindest an den Stellen wo sich
russische Truppen zurückgezogen haben
oder geflüchtet sind dass den Ukrainern
ermöglicht relativ schnell nachzustoßen
das gleiche könnte man mit einem
Schützenpanzer allerdings auch machen
und eine weitere Frage in Bezug auf auf
diesen Komplex vielleicht noch von User
conversus er fragt warum wird nicht
eigentlich mehr über die Lieferung von
bergepanzern berichtet für ihn viel
zielführender als Leopard Panzer gehen
sie damit
nein da gehe ich nicht mit die Ukraine
hat Bergepanzer bekommen und bekommt
Bergepanzer aus Deutschland auch
diese Fahrzeuge sind einfach notwendig
wenn wir brückenlegepanzer oder
Flakpanzer liefern und bei diesem Panzer
Ausfälle auftreten dann müssen diese
Kampffahrzeuge geborgen werden und dafür
gibt es Bergepanzer und wir haben auch
bereits Bergepanzer geliefert dann
richten wir den Fokus auf einen weiteren
Aspekt der auch im Stimmungsbild von
allem eine Anmerkung na klar darf ich
noch mal eine Anmerkung machen der
Vorteil der Vorteil dabei ist der das
beispielsweise der Flakpanzer Geppert in
wesentlichen Teilen auf dem Fahrgestell
des Kampfpanzer Leopard 1 beruht berührt
und der Bergepanzer den wir dort
hingeliefert haben ebenfalls auf dem
Fahrgestell des Leopard 1 das heißt das
ist keine zusätzliche Belastung für die
Versorgung für die Logistik
haben wir das auch gelernt vielen Dank
ich wollte gerade den Fokus auf die
Aufmerksamkeit richten bzw auf den
Aspekt der vom Stimmungsbild von Alisa
in Kiew hervorgekommen ist das ist der
Faktor Zeit Stichwort Winter der
bevorsteht und da sagt User Tom Frank
oder Frank
er bittet sie eigentlich quasi zu diesem
Faktor was zu sagen wie entscheidend ist
denn jetzt gerade der Faktor Zeit und
auch ja der Winter der bevorsteht
oder bevorstehende Winter wird in der
Ukraine sicherlich härter ausfallen dass
Sie hier bei uns in Mitteleuropa oder in
Deutschland ausfällt wir sind hier in
den letzten Jahren von Schnee nicht so
sonderlich verwöhnt worden und von Frost
auch nicht das sieht für die Ukraine
anders aus die Ukraine ist ein relativ
offenes Land und sie unterliegt dann dem
Kontinentalklima das heißt man muss
davon ausgehen dass Kälte mit
entsprechenden stürmen und Wind und
Schneefall von Osten her in die Ukraine
reinkommt das bedeutet eine Veränderung
der Bodenverhältnisse damit
möglicherweise auch eine Veränderung der
Kampfweise sowohl der ukrainischen als
auch der russischen Kräfte aber der
Winter wird auch die ukrainische
Bevölkerung sehr hart treffen weil
natürlich die Mittel und Möglichkeiten
über die Energieversorgung in der
Ukraine deutlich eingeschränkt sind die
Ukraine hat zwar nach wie vor das
Potenzial auch mit ihren Atomkraftwerken
genügend Strom herzustellen aber ich
gehe trotzdem davon aus dass der Winter
für die ukrainische Bevölkerung in
diesem Jahr eine sehr unangenehme
Erscheinung sein wird wobei ich auch
feststellen möchte dass die Ukraine
offensichtlich in diesen Fragen ganz
schön hart im Nehmen sind das hat sich
im Prinzip im Februar März diesen Jahres
auch schon gezeigt und ich denke dass
die ukrainische Bevölkerung trotzdem
trotz Kälte möglicherweise auch trotz
Frost und trotz wintererscheinungen ihre
Kampfmoral und ihre inneren Willen ihr
die Streitkräfte zu Unterstützung
deshalb nicht aufgeben wird sind an
dieser Stelle auch weitere Unterstützung
aus dem Westen entscheidend
ja womit wollen wir unterstützen in
diesem Falle also wir können weder
Energie dorthin liefern noch können wir
noch können wir was weiß ich Kohle oder
andere Brennstoffe dorthin bringen die
Liefermöglichkeiten sind eingesteckt und
die Versorgungsketten sind zur
Versorgung der Bevölkerung zum Teil
bereits stark beansprucht
beziehungsweise in einigen Bereichen
sogar überbeansprucht das heißt
Brennmaterial ja theoretisch könnte
Polen beispielsweise Kohl in großem
Umfang liefern das wäre eine Möglichkeit
um zumindest die die ich sag mal die
thematischen Auswirkungen hinsichtlich
der Kälte für die ukrainische
Bevölkerung zu mindern wir müssen sehen
wie weit das geht und ich bitte einfach
um Verständnis dass ich hier nicht
weiter spekulieren möchte da ich in
diesen Fragen kein Wirtschaftsfachmann
kann energiefachmann nennen absolut dann
sprechen wir noch mal auch über unser
übergeordnetes Thema und das ist eben
die Situation der russischen
Streitkräfte da haben wir schon
detailliert beschrieben dass die aktuell
ja in einem sehr schwierigen in einem
fast schon desaströsen Zustand sein
könnte und da kommt von Herbert
gellereut auf Facebook auch die Frage
noch mal an sie ist es nicht
mittlerweile also auch vor allem die
ganze russische Kriegsführung einfach
ein einziges Desaster aus dem man auch
gar nicht mehr rauskommt
also die Situation ist aus russischer
Sicht das möchte ich in aller
Deutlichkeit sagen eine ausgesprochen
schwierige nach meiner Bewertung ob sie
nach der Bewertung des Präsidenten oder
des Verteidigungsministers wurde es
Generalstabschefs als so schwierig
bewertet wird kann ich nicht beurteilen
aber auch dort gibt es ja Anzeichen
aufgrund von Interviews aufgrund von
Berichterstattung aufgrund der
Forderungen die Herr kadirov gestellt
hat dass man offensichtlich mit diesen
ich sag mal mit dieser Führung wie sie
dort stattfindet sehr unzufrieden ist
und es gibt auch in den Berichten
mittlerweile Beispiele dafür wo ich sage
das ist mit Blick auf den Umgang mit
russischen Soldaten verantwortungslos
was dort getrieben wird wenn ich höre in
berichten dass frisch rekrutierte Männer
mehr oder weniger eingekleidet und
vielleicht mit einem Gewehr ausgerüstet
in die Ukraine transportiert werden dort
noch vor Ort eine kurze Ausbildung
bekommen und dann in den Kampf geschickt
werden sollen dann ist das auch
gegenüber der eigenen Bevölkerung
menschenverachten in aller Deutlichkeit
gesagt und ist etwas was man weder als
militärischer Vorgesetzter noch als
Präsident zulassen sollte weil das
letztendlich zu weiteren hohen Verlusten
führt und der ein oder andere
Kommentator oder der ein oder andere
Fachmann hat in diesem Bereich ja auch
schon den Begriff Kanonenfutter
gebraucht und das wäre eine entsetzliche
Sache
trotzdem treibt Wladimir Putin genau
dieser Aspekte die sie gerade als das
benennen was sie sind weiter voran
vielleicht nur zwei Aspekte noch zum
Schluss auch wenn Sie sicherlich oder
wir alle natürlich nicht in den Kopf von
Wladimir Putin schauen können aber wie
bewerten sie sozusagen diese Entwicklung
am Anfang gesagt ich mache hier eine
militärische spezialoperation jetzt
weite ich diesen Krieg aus und dieses
Festhalten und kein Eingeständnis zeigen
wie beurteilen sie da diese Entwicklung
in seinen Aussagen in sein
Verhaltensweisen und dem nicht
anerkennen von teilweise auch rationalen
Fakten
also es zeigt ich stecke nicht in seinem
Kopf vielleicht aus erste Bemerkung dazu
aber es zeigt dass er offensichtlich
bestimmte Dinge mit Blick auf den Krieg
in der Ukraine anders sieht als wir sie
wahrnehmen und als wir sie mit einer so
sage ich das mal objektiveren Bericht
Erstattung aufnehmen und beurteilen
können ich kann nicht beurteilen wie
weit er sachgerecht von seinen
Mitarbeitern aus dem Generalstab aber
aus dem Nationalen Sicherheitsrat
informiert wird oder ob er tatsächlich
in einem Elfenbeinturm sitzt wo
offensichtlich die Lagebeurteilung von
seiner eigenen Seite her nicht mehr
richtig funktioniert aber wir müssen uns
zu einem klaren sein dass seine
Perzeption und seine Wahrnehmung wie er
sie hat von dem Lauf dieses Krieges
letztendlich für seine Entscheidung
ausschlaggebend ist das heißt wir werden
mit diesem ich sage das mal miserablen
Zustand dass dort irrationale aus
unserer Sicht irrationale Entscheidung
gefällt werden weiter leben und müssen
auch damit umgehen und wir dürfen uns
dadurch auch nicht
sage ich mal Angst einjagen lassen weil
Angst ist ein schlechter Ratgeber in
solchen Fällen und wir müssen versuchen
die irrationaler eher handelt und
entscheidet um so sachlicher selber die
Sachen zu beurteilen und umso sachlicher
auch dann entsprechend die Entscheidung
zu fällen die notwendig sind um a eine
weitere Eskalation zu vermeiden und B
auf der anderen Seite die ukrainische
Bevölkerung und das EU keine selber
entsprechend weiter in diesem
Aggressionskrieg Völkerrechts wie in
Aggressionskrieg zur unterstützen dann
lösen wir uns genau von diesen
angststörenden Aspekten und richten den
Blick noch mal auf einen Ausblick auf
eine Prognose und eine generelle
kontextuierung wir haben ja in den
vergangenen Wochen mit verschiedenen
auch mit ihnen militärexpertinnen
Experten über die Situation gesprochen
es wurde an der ein oder anderen Stelle
von allen möglichen Wendepunkt
gesprochen von einem Kulminationspunkt
an welchem Punkt stehen wir und wie
ordnen Sie die weitere Zeitachse im
weiteren Verlauf ein
also wir stehen im Augenblick an einem
Punkt der für die Ukraine zurzeit
positiv ist das heißt die Ukraine muss
das was sie jetzt in ihren Handlungen
Angriffshandlungen der gleichen mehr
erreicht hat weiter ausnutzen können
dazu bedarf sie der Unterstützung des
Westens ich möchte noch nicht von einem
Wendepunkt reden weil ich nicht weiß was
Putin möglicherweise noch ins Gefecht
führen kann er hat noch genügend Truppen
in Russland er hat vielleicht heute was
die Ukraine angeht mit allen
Unterstützung dabei 60 Prozent der
russischen Landstreitkräfte eingesetzt
mehr nicht das heißt es sind noch 40
Prozent da das heißt auf der anderen
Seite aber auch dass er nicht in der
Lage sein wird eine zweite Front zu
eröffnen egal wo von daher kann er aber
diese 40 Prozent auch noch in der
Ukraine einsetzen und das könnte dann
durchaus auch noch mal Vorteile für die
Kriegsführung der Russen bringen wir
wissen auch nicht welche Dinge er
möglicherweise noch in der Tasche hat
und aus der Tasche rausholen wird und
hier Erfolge zu erzielen ich denke daran
dass er beispielsweise Weißrussland
Belarus zwingen könnte in den Krieg
einzusteigen was Lukaschenko bisher
verweigert hat in den gesamten
Kriegshandlungen seit dem 24 februar
haben weißrussische Truppen die Grenze
zur Ukraine nicht überschritten das sind
alles noch Spielmöglichkeiten die da
sind für ihn und mit denen er durchaus
die Lage noch verändern könnte
die Situation sieht für die Ukraine
zurzeit gut aus ich hoffe dass das so
bleibt aber ich möchte noch einmal
betonen dass die Ukraine dabei von einer
andauernden fortgesetzten und mit den
erforderlichen Mittel versehenen
westlichen Unterstützung abhängig ist
sagt Egon Rams klare Forderung hier bei
ZDF heute live der ehemalige
Nato-General vielen Dank Herr Rams für
ihre Analysen für ihre Hintergründe und
für ihre Expertise die mit uns geteilt
haben
Erhöhung gerne herzlichen Dank
ich bedanke mich auch bei euch natürlich
fürs fleißig kommentieren fürs Fragen
stellen fürs zuschauen ich habe es
gerade vergessen Herrn Rams noch weiter
zu leiten vielleicht hört er es ja noch
sehr viel positives Feedback auch für
seine Analysen und seine Einschätzung
ganz herzlichen Dank für heute wir sehen
uns wieder und ich würde mich freuen
wenn ihr dann auch wieder mit im Stream
seid ciao